Charlie: Salman Khan is here.
He's the founder of Khan Academy,
the online learning tube that has
reached and taught millions.
Forbes Magazine calls it the
largest school in the world.
Bill Gates calls him a true pioneer.
Khan Academy's goal is to provide a free
world class education for anyone anywhere.
Salman Khan has written a book describing
how such a vision might be achieved.
It is called The One World School House,
Education Reimagined.
I am pleased to have him
back on this program.
Welcome.
Sal: Great to be here.
Charlie: When you were
here, we talked about
how this whole thing started for you
and the development with your niece
who was down in Louisiana and you were
teaching her and you used
YouTube and all of that.
Where is it now?
Sal: Yeah, I think when we last spoke,
I think it was about 18 months ago,
I think we were reaching on the order of
about a million students every month.
We're now at 6 million
students every month.
The team is growing ... I
think when we last talked,
it was a 5% team, we're
now approaching 40 people
and it's really about not just the videos,
although the videos are still
a big part of what we do,
I'm not the only person
making videos anymore,
we're now translating the videos into
every major language in the world,
our software platform is
being used in classrooms
and outside of classrooms
around the world.
It's just where it was before,
but maybe 10 times bigger.
Charlie: You think you were born to teach?
Sal: I enjoy it. (laughing)
I wasn't born to play
basketball. (laughing)
Charlie: Me neither. (laughing)
But fact that you did
have a passion for it,
you had a technique for it and you found
more love for it than you did being,
obviously because you left being in
the hedge fund world.
Sal: Most people don't
realize the commonality
between what I was doing before and what
I hope I'm doing now.
Even at the hedge fund
world, it was actually
an intellectually intriguing job.
In some ways, it wasn't
different from what
you're doing now.
You have to context switch
from one space to another,
you're constantly learning,
you get to talk to a lot of
people to learn from them,
and so for me, a big
fun part of that job was
I always got to learn stuff.
I couldn't communicate it as much
as I might have wanted to.
Now I get the chance to do both.
Charlie: Where can you take this?
Sal: A couple of things
that we're working on,
I mentioned we're translating the videos,
but we're also internationalizing
the entire site.
We already have partners;
the Carlos Slim Foundation
in Latin America, The
Lemon Foundation in Brazil,
we recently took a trip down to Brazil
and there's national interest,
the president had asked,
"What are we going to
be able to do together?"
Charlie: In Brazil?
Sal: In Brazil. I think in the next year
you're going to see Khan
Academy going global
in a much more significant way.
I think you're going to see,
it started with videos,
we've had an online
component exercises, we
can give people feedback
on where they are, but we're going to make
that much, much more serious.
The 48 states have adopted
the common core standards.
There aren't any assessments out.
There are some groups out there that are
going to be developing assessments.
Through this whole transition,
you're going to have teachers, parents and
students wondering about how do they
navigate the switch and
what we hope to do is
take our exercises and turn them into
really rigorous
assessments so that you can
go to the site and get a
really strong diagnostic
of what you know and what you don't know
so we can narrow you in,
"Here's what you need to work on."
We can kind of coach you
through that process,
the tools for the teachers will get better
and we also want to figure out a way
for you to get credit for what you know.
Charlie: How far away are you from that?
Sal: We've had a lot of
interesting conversations.
Charlie: What's the resistance?
Sal: Maybe we're just
not seeing the resistance
because we're not that far along yet,
but especially if you
talk about some of the
core college courses or the
late high school courses,
right now you have 70% of students who
go to community college
have to take remedial Math.
They usually don't find
that out until they
show up and start paying tuition.
This is something that
no one wants to happen
and it's the biggest predictor of whether
they're going to be able to finish or not.
If we can address that so ahead of time
someone could show,
"Look, I know my Algebra.
I know my pre-Algebra,
I know my Trigonometry.
I'm ready to engage," if someone can prove
that even at the professional level,
"Hey, I can program a
computer. I might not
have the four year degree,
but I'm employable."
We think that could have
huge implications for;
one, someone who doesn't have a chance to
a traditional university
or even some of the
structural unemployment issues.
We think it's, structural unemployment,
there's a skills gap,
but we think it's even
more a singling gap that ...
Charlie: Signaling ...
Sal: Singling gap ...
That you do have people
who actually do have skills and there's
no way for them to prove it.
Right now we have that problem where
people are learning to
do stuff on Khan Academy
and they want to prove it to the world,
but there's no way for
them to prove that ...
Charlie: That they know something.
Sal: That they know something.
We have accounting videos on Khan.
You can actually learn
on a pretty decent level.
We have a lot more to
do, but there's no way
for them to validate that,
so we imagine a world
where a few years out
someone will be able to.
Charlie: Who would set the standard?
Sal: I think for any type of credential
the key is, who is going to be consumer of
the credential? Who does it matter to?
For someone wanting to prove that
they know Algebra, we
have to go to universities
and make sure that you feel this is
a credible standard that
someone has attained.
If you're talking about does someone know
how to program or does someone have good
critical thinking skills
or does someone write well,
I think you go straight
to the employers and say,
"Would you respect this
type of a credential?"
The thing we point out is even today,
a very expensive credentials have limited
information in them.
You could go to a fancy
university and when
a company like Google or
Microsoft interviews you,
they still assume very little.
They make you go through a very ...
The first interview is,
"Go write Bubble Sword
on the whiteboard," which
is what you typically
learn the first three weeks
of Computer Science class
and this someone who's
gone through four years.
To some degree, if you
could take that process
and turn it into a credential,
and tell the rest of the world,
"You don't have to go
to a fancy university,
but if you can get to this threshold,
you get to round three
of the interview process
at Software Company X or
Fortune 500 Company Y,"
it could be a powerful thing.
Charlie: This is not a silver bullet,
but there is some magic here.
What is it that you
understood about learning
when you taught your niece way back when?
Sal: Yeah, and I'll
emphasize that it's not
a silver bullet. (laughter)
The biggest criticism we get is,
"This is not a silver bullet."
It's like, "I agree!"
Charlie: What I mean
by that is that there's
no easy way here, you're
just helping people
learn better.
Sal: Right.
Charlie: Or helping them learn themselves,
teach themselves to learn.
Sal: That's the key and
that's what we always
want to point out is that for us, for me,
to really educate someone doesn't mean
to try to pour information
into their brain
and hope that they can regurgitate it out,
it's to really allow
them, give them the tools
so that they can take agency
over their own learning.
We all say that's the real skill.
If you can factor a
polynomial, that's nice,
but if you can go out into the workforce
and some new technology emerges or
some new issue comes and you can take
ownership of it and learn it,
that's what you want people to be at.
I think what we tapped into,
initially it was me making
stuff for my cousins,
is put stuff out there
that respects the learner,
that's approachable,
that's conversational,
that really gives people
the thinking behind
something, not just the formula and you
let them access it on their own terms.
There's huge need for that.
Charlie: Can you monetize this?
Sal: It's an interesting question.
We're not-for-profit, so that means
no one owns Khan Academy,
but still we have to
sustain ourselves in some way.
Not-for-profit doesn't mean that you can't
generate revenue, universities
do that quite well.
(laughter)
On top of being not-for-profit,
we have in our Mission Statement
a "free world class education
for anyone anywhere"
so we've kind of limited
ourselves in terms of
we're not going to charge.
We're committed to not
charging for the learning part.
So far, we're philanthropically supported
and hopefully that can
always make that case,
it's hard to have a
more scalable social ROI
return on your investment,
but we are discovering
that we've inadvertently built a brand.
With that brand, we are
starting to license the content,
we're starting to do
some brand partnerships,
people will start hearing more about that
in the next couple of
months, that are actually
helping pay for a significant amount
of our operating budget.
Charlie: How about Corporate America
or Corporate World?
Sal: I think there's a few companies ...
Charlie: The training of workforce is a
crucial ingredient of what you do.
Sal: Yes, so there's two elements of that.
One is a lot of corporations feel that
they're not able to find
the talent that they need
to fill certain slots.
So we can either help the world ramp up
with those skills and then help prove that
they know those skills
... And then I think
what you're eluding to is this idea of
even in corporate training itself,
this whole self-paced model
makes a lot more sense.
You're sitting at your desk,
you want to improve your skills
in one vertical or another,
you do it at your own time and pace.
It is something that we've talked to some
people about, corporate training.
A lot of corporations
are starting to realize
that the best thing they
can do for the customer
is educate the customers about the domain
that they're in, so we're starting to
do stuff there as well.
Charlie: Why did you call this
"The One World School House?"
Sal: This was the working title at first
and it was the working title because
I always used to say the irony is a lot of
what you're talking about is going back
to the one-room schoolhouse where you have
multi-age classrooms,
much more interactive,
kids taking agency,
responsibility for each other,
It was like, "Yeah, but
there's some neat things here.
Any kid in the world can access this.
We can connect any student in the world."
There's another element
to it which I talk about.
I want to take the lecture off the table
in the classroom so that the classroom
can engage with the world
in a more relevant way.
It just sounded kind of a fun,
instead of one room
schoolhouse, one world.
Charlie: That goes to the core here and
I really am interested
in the experience from
the learner's standpoint.
Obviously the part of your notion is that
what we understood, as
the classroom method
of teaching is not preordained,
as the best way to teach.
Sal: Absolutely. If you
go back 400 years ago
and you saw the few
people who were getting an
education 400 years ago, it
pretty much private tutor.
Private tutor was self-paced,
you master a concept, now let me ...
Charlie: And mastery's crucial.
Sal: Mastery's crucial.
If you don't master
pre-Algebra, it's kind
of nuts to expect you
to understand Algebra or Trig-,
but right now you can barely pass Algebra
and they're going to
stick you in Algebra II
or they're going to stick you in ...
What happened is about 200,
and I go into the history
a bit in the book about,
a little over 200 years
ago, the Prussians,
now somewhat part of Germany,
were the first to say,
"We want a large labor force,"
and it's the beginning of
the industrial revolution, "Let's
have universal public education."
It's actually a pretty
profound thing that they did,
but then say, "How do we do
it in an economical way?"
They said, "Well, maybe we
batch students together,
we see how some of these factories are
starting to get built, how
do they do things at scale?"
We batch students together,
moving them in a line as a set pace,
we try to pour knowledge into their heads,
some kids it'll stick, some it won't.
At some point we start
sorting the oranges;
these kids are going to be juiced
and these kids are going
to go to whole food.
(laughter)
There's an element of
even the old Prussian
model of some degree of indoctrination.
And then in the mid-1800s,
the US famously said,
"We want to have universal
public education."
It's no coincidence.
Charlie: So we base it
on the Prussian model?
Sal: We base it on the Prussian model.
The Japanese too, it's no coincidence.
These are the industrial
superpowers that emerged
because they had a middle
class that was educated.
They fundamentally
didn't rethink the model.
I talk about it in the
book, it was actually
a discovery to me when I was doing some
of the research ... Why
do they always teach
Physics in the 12th grade?
Why do they teach Chemistry
in the 11th grade?
Where did this come from?
It came from literally a group of 10 men
about 120 years ago,
before the internet or DNA
or anything, that said people should learn
Geometry in the 10th grade,
people should have three years of English,
and it hasn't changed.
It's pretty much frozen there.
What we're saying is a lot
of the ideas aren't new.
Let's master a concept,
let's personalize the
instruction to the student,
this is what would have
been the gold standard
300 years ago and even 50 years ago.
If you said, "What's the best?"
"Well, personalized instruction."
Now could you do that for every student?
No, it's very expensive. You'd have to
hire a teacher for every student.
What's interesting
about technology is that
now we can go through the
same thought experiment
and say maybe we can do personalized
instruction for every
student if we rethink
the role of the teacher,
if we move them up
the value chain instead of them just being
a lecturer, we let them see data where
every student is, every student is going
at their own pace mastering concepts.
We leverage the fact that the students
can teach each other,
this is kind of where
the one-room schoolhouse comes in.
That's another mid-level skill that
I think is lost today.
It nice to be able to factor a polynomial,
but the ability to take leadership
and the ability to
actually manage your peers,
if you're a 16-year-old,
you're now leading
some 12-year-olds, you're
teaching them things.
Can we start to leverage in that way?
Everything we're writing
here is like, yeah,
I think we can, and not only can we,
we're doing it, we're seeing it.
Khan Academy is a part
of it, but we're able
to work with schools today that are
actually experimenting here.
Charlie: You also say that face time
should be separate, it's a separate thing
from mastery of concepts.
Sal: Right now face time and seat time,
whatever you want to call it,
it's there at the university level,
so the point that your units are called,
they're literally seat time
units, three credit hours,
six credit hours is how many
hours you sat in a chair.
What we're saying is, "Why don't you go to
a competency model where it's not how long
you sat in the chair, but did you learn
the material at a level of mastery
whether it took you five days to do it
or five years to do it, that's irrelevant,
you got to the level."
The other is when you get human beings
together in a room, a lot of people say,
"This video lecture stuff, I enjoy it,
but I love my college lectures where
I could ask a question."
I'm like, "Hey, that's exactly the point.
Instead of questions being 5% of the time,
it should be 100% of the time.
There should be none of the students just
sitting passive and whether
you have 10 students
in the room, 20 students in the room
or 2,000 students in the room,
if you're having a passive lecture,
it doesn't matter.
There's no interactivity.
We've all sat in a college lecture,
even in high school and
we're all in the room
together, but we're not
able to talk to each other.
It's actually incredibly dehumanizing that
you're getting no interactivity.
What we're saying is
a lot of your exposure
to the concepts, and once again,
humanities have been doing
this for a long time,
"Go read the chapter and we're going to
discuss it when we come to class.
We're going to have an interactive thing."
Charlie: What's the
difference or why students
feel more passionate about their sports
coaches than they do
about their Math teachers?
Sal: Yes, this is something
that I feel strong ...
I saw it in high school.
You're in 10th grade Algebra class,
the teacher asks the
students to do six problems,
"Oh my God," they're
groaning and they're like,
"He's the meanest guy
on the planet," and then
three hours later, we're
at wrestling practice
and the teacher says, "I want you to do
50 pushups followed by
running three miles,
followed by another 50
pushups," and they're like,
"Yes Sir! Yes Sir! Push me harder!
I wanna collapse!" Literally, sometimes
people would collapse they're
willing to work so hard.
Charlie: What's the difference?
Sal: The difference is that they feel that
the coach is on their side, that the coach
is preparing them for battle.
Charlie: It's in their
interest to do what he says.
Sal: It's in their interest.
They're training me.
While the unfortunate
thing is that even though
the Math teacher cares
just as much or more
about the student, the
Math teacher's viewed
as an adversary, "This is the person who's
going to keep me from passing. This is the
person that's trying
flunk ... ," even though
that's not what the
motivations of the teacher are.
What we're advocating, what we're seeing
is working well and the teachers we've
worked with really love it is,
become that coach and
you don't have to become
both the assessor and the
lecturer and the coach,
be that coach figure, be that mentor.
You'll form a deeper
connection with the students,
and you're preparing them
for an outside world.
It's a very subtle but
powerful mindset change.
Charlie: You have pathway to excellence.
Sal: Exactly. I had a
dinner, I happened to be
sitting next to Wendy
Kopp, Teach for America,
and we just randomly
started talking about,
"What do you notice amongst
the Teach for America
teachers that are really
able to move the dial?"
She says, "It's actually
surprising, most people
think it would be about content delivery;
who can give the best
lecture, who could ... "
Charlie: Who has magic as a teacher?
Sal: Yeah, because movies try to ...
And they do have magic,
but it's a different
type of magic."
It's the teachers who can change the
students' mindsets, who
can be that older brother
or father or that mother figure and say,
"Look, this is a do or
die situation and if
you want to be able to
survive in this world,
I'm here for you, but it's
your decision to make."
The same type of psychology
that a coach does.
Those are the ones, once
you get the student,
once it clicks in their brain,
"Wait, I have to take ownership here."
Charlie: On a football team
you got to learn the plays.
Sal: Exactly, and you have to
take ownership for yourself.
"It's not me, it's you. You're
going to make it or you're not
and I'm just here to help
you." That changes the ...
Charlie: "I can't play the game for you,
you have to play it yourself."
Sal: Exactly.
Charlie: So when you look
at the next five years,
where might I see Khan
Academy in five years?
I mean, is it simply a multiplier effect
of how many kids you can reach?
Sal: It's definitely
that, so in five years
I hope we're reaching
50, who knows what might
happen with internationalization.
I hope that you see,
especially even in places
where they don't have access, although I
think the access issue is going to get
solved to a large degree in the next
five years with cheaper
tablets and more internet ...
Charlie: Throughout education?
Sal: Throughout education,
but even outside
of formal education systems, NGOs are
going to be able to give tablets to kids.
I think it'll be some of
the ideas in the book that
right now like, "No more
lectures in the classrooms?"
I think they're going to
start being maintstream.
I think you're going to start seeing
top institutions realize
that it's in their
best interest to not define themselves by,
"I gave a good lecture that's passive,"
but what's the formal experience that
I do on my campus?"
I think when you do
that, when people realize
that it's not an either or,
that these are tools
that will help students
take ownership, then it frees up
the physical environment to go deeper.
I think that'll be a
mainstream thing in five years.
Charlie: Where are we in terms of
online education in the evolution,
because it didn't deliver what many
people thought it would once they
understood that it could be a tool?
Sal: Yes, you had a first wave in the late
'90s, early 2000s, it was kind
of obvious. The internet's
about disseminating
information ...hey, education.
Charlie: It came along
when the development
of the PC, I assume?
Sal: Steve Jobs famously
originally thought
that the personal computer was going to be
the treadmill for the brain.
He thought that was the killer app for
the computer; it ended up
being for other things,
and obviously it helped
people learn as well,
but it didn't really hit
the nail on the head there.
Then with the internet, even pre-computer,
the radio people thought was going to be
the killer app for education.
They thought TV, VCR, these are all ...
TV's here, it's On Demand now. (laughter)
I think what happened in maybe about
five, six years ago,
you can't underestimate
YouTube's power here where it really
lowered the cost of streaming video,
producing and streaming
video close to zero
to the point that a guy in his closet
could start making it
for his cousins and ...
Charlie: That's you ...
Sal: That was me, and
start getting traction.
I think that helped
kind of show people that
there's a demand here and not just for the
videos, but for the whole interactive
immersive experience, so this past year
you've had these moocs emerge,
these massively openly online courses,
Harvard, MIT, edX, there's a group
from Stanford, other folks who have been
doing it, and what really seems ...
Charlie: For credit?
Sal: Right now, for the most part,
they're issuing certificates, although
they are starting to partner with a few
institutions for credit as well.
So it's really different this time.
It looks like all of the players,
including us, are looking at how do we
systemically become
important to the system?
With a blank slate ...
What is the whole point of education?
What is the whole point of a credential?
How do we do that in
the best possible way?
Either outside of the system
or in partnership with it.
Charlie: Thank you. Great to see you.
Sal: It's great to be here.
Charlie: The One World
Schoolhouse Education
Reimagined, Salman Khan, Khan Academy.
Thank you again.
Thank you for joining us.
See you next time.